and you get home and risk like I mean
this is a never-ending repetition right
hello and welcome to this video and I
want to play some games and you have the
same guy playing b3 every single friggin
game come on i do something crazy now
I'm just fed up with this stuff baby you
place the same crap every game that's
great I'm just I just don't want this
anymore I want out yeah come on and you
[ __ ] slip ridiculous of course
hahahaha and layered and this is really
alice is so boring he plays the same
opening every game like not even a
little bit of variety and you never have
anything I mean absolutely never okay so
let's see what this is is this crazy g5
yeah hey you want to trade Queens that's
cool that's not exactly reputation here
how do you do it c6 I can taking is a
little bit so that's wrong but maybe I
can get see feiven make him take and
Queenie for maybe now can't doesn't
really doesn't really matter Wow okay
yeah I'm fine I'm getting away with this
crap that's funny did you try to review
it
a4 it's a normal idea here I don't mmmm
I don't think he should go what what
what is that I am not sure what this
looked us prevents a for it still looks
strange
let's check the weakness night is not
bad on b6 anyway I could do this
actually that's interesting let's do it
it takes with the bishop 96 looks good
yes y notas point x 96 also looks quite
sensible
Janet hmm interesting neither form makes
a lot of sense so good square but just
96 would fit here I can also take be
three maybe but that's a little bit
that's a bit much he might play before
like Knight b6 before so it's possible
hmm yeah that's very much possible I
think I have to do this attack him ok
now if I take here Knight takes bishop
shakes it's a little bit inconvenient
but I have to I have to get it back I
mean I cannot sacrifice something here
yeah now looky 7 is just around the
corner I don't think it's particularly
dangerous but also nothing great c4 is
an interesting move that you just now
has prevented ok but on the other hand
on the other hand there's nothing
special going on here looks you want
Bishop f5 and threatening to play and
this should be six so the loop only
seven is quite misplaced maybe you
create but then takes rook takes Bishop
you one is always ok i would go too soon
yeah
should be fine maybe he doesn't know
goes back I can still play but should be
six threatening we should take see form
like bishop on a4 is a little bit
strange so it comes that can try to look
before and try that threaten that again
[Music]
now i'm not actually threatening it as a
three maybe i can play like c65
now see 65 is on the agenda not sure
that next all that much but it's
something that I can try okay puts all
kinds of pawns on light squares why for
whatever reason don't quite get why I
mean you're not supposed to do that
right okay so he stops this it still
extremely difficult to do anything here
once position is still extremely solid
can take c6 now I can take the fog that
doesn't work then that wasn't a good
idea allow me this d5 move okay a selfie
yeah that's not a bad idea probably you
cannot do much here with black so take
g5 so that it doesn't get into a meeting
net yep yeah it's unfortunately nothing
I can't do him yes extremely dry maybe
he can try something
no okay
okay no let's not stumble into this now
he's got no time here whatsoever the 55
is made though I wish you at five is
also made Wow ok and after pinner yeah I
was very strange game very strange I
wonder I mean he looks kind of okay but
I didn't didn't really get anywhere
s-sorry about my rents in the opening I
just don't understand why you can play
the single every single game the same
bad opening where why does fighting for
equality I mean I don't understand it
ready ok gphi this crap but I just what
did something up so when he never tried
to to refute again after the Queen track
like is fine of course Jim maybe I
should have put the bishop on d 7
instead of b7 I mean this is this is
very ok but I can actually take huh that
I didn't think I thought about it but I
thought it just wouldn't work huh I'm
amazed that the engine think this is
equal why this
this should be eight okay that would be
true that it is not very human that this
is okay some house and here we're
probably just going into somewhat equal
position yeah I have to better plan
structure and he made it worse the whole
time with g 4 and so on it really
doesn't make any sense there's no reason
to do it but it's it's very
fortress-like we cannot cannot do much I
mean what I try to FC 65 is probably not
even all that great yeah that was a good
decision the position now is much easier
for y to play then for me DNA was just
too slow I'm not sure if I was lost
there maybe I was yeah yeah now the
engine is not all that pessimistic King
III and by wide span I of course if
anybody with white is better kini hi I
don't know the only thing that I would
really like to see like just once having
placed some other move I mean anyway
okay thanks for watching